[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you so much for
joining us today, Michelle.
MICHELLE LEE: Of course.
Thank you for having me.
SPEAKER: So what is it
like to be editor-in-chief
at "Allure" magazine?
MICHELLE LEE: Oh,
what a question.
So I always think of it
as-- so I've been working
in media for the past 25 years.
And when I first started out,
the role of the editor-in-chief
was completely different.
So my first role here in New
York was actually at "Glamour."
And so at the time, it
was "Glamour" magazine.
The editor-in-chief was this
totally legendary editor
named Ruth Whitney.
And so she had that
one role though,
which was to be the
editor-in-chief of a magazine.
I think today being an
editor-in-chief is almost
being the shepherd of a brand.
So I've been there now
for about 3 and 1/2 years.
And when I started,
I was very much
seen as this new realm
of editor-in-chief who
was sort of like the modern
editor who understood print,
and digital, and
video, and social,
and all those different things.
So one of my
biggest things to do
was to have everybody understand
that we're not just a magazine
anymore.
So I remember when
I first started,
people would still
introduce themselves
and say, I'm so-and-so.
I'm an editor at
"Allure" magazine.
So we very much, like, that
first week, we're like,
you're not an editor
at "Allure" magazine,
you're an editor at "Allure."
And it was shifting the
viewpoint of everyone
internally, but also
externally to have
them understand we're
not just a magazine,
we're now a media brand.
So flash forward
3 and 1/2 years,
and I actually see
it much differently
now where we're not just a media
brand, but we're also a brand.
So we were talking
before we came up here
about one of our businesses
is the "Allure" Beauty Box.
So we now are in
consumer products.
We're doing events.
We're doing all those
other media things as well.
But I think that what's been
really innovative in the past 3
and 1/2 years that
I've been there
has been us shifting
from being just media
into being an overall brand.
So yes, but to answer your
question also about what is it
like to be the editor-in-chief,
on social media
if anyone follows me, we play
with a lot of beauty products.
Like it's definitely
a very, very fun job.
I have a couple of my
coworkers here who--
it's probably one of the only
offices that you can walk into
and it's completely
normal to walk by someone
and they're putting on
a full face of makeup.
We actually are testing for our
"Allure" Best of Beauty Awards
right now.
And so every season, we test
10,000 products just for that.
So it sounds so fun
and it is very fun,
but it's also
incredibly overwhelming
because we go home every
single day with just bags
and bags of stuff.
So that's the fun part of it.
Like, I think playing
with beauty products,
getting to understand everything
about the beauty industry.
But I think being an editor in
chief, also, is a lot of work.
I think a lot of
times, people in media
and in movies and
stuff have this picture
of what an editor in chief does.
For example, "The Devil
Wears Prada," right?
I think that we all have this
image of what the Miranda
Priestly character does.
I always describe being an
editor in chief, though,
sort of like being the
director of a movie.
For some of my family members,
for example, who don't really
understand what an editor is,
I often got the question, like,
what does an editor do?
Are you fixing the commas
and periods all the time?
I'm like, that's a part
of it, but really, it's
being the director
of a movie, where
I am the key
decision maker in all
the different creative choices.
So if we also wanted to get
into some new business--
if we wanted to launch a
line of brushes or makeup
bags or anything
else, I would be
involved in the entire
creative process of it, too.
So I think that my role now--
honestly, it touches a lot
more on the business side
than I ever could have
imagined 20 years ago.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Well this next
question comes more
from a personal spot for me.
The publishing
industry in general
is overwhelmingly white.
We're talking about novels,
magazines, et cetera.
And growing up as a
young girl, I rarely
saw models looking like
myself when I was--
MICHELLE LEE: Where
did you grow up?
SPEAKER: In Canada,
in Vancouver.
So when I was there, I never
saw a lot of cover models
who looked like me or who
were different on covers.
And so this year alone,
in 2019, Serena Williams
was your January cover.
Then you had "Crazy Rich
Asians" star Gemma Chan
in another cover.
So how do you approach
diversity at the organization,
and then how do you also
make that trickle down,
beyond just editor in chief?
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, well I think
it's a couple different things.
Part of it is, internally,
how we look at our staff,
how we look at
hiring, and I actually
do think that that's very much
related to the type of content,
then, that we produce, also.
So in the 3 and 1/2 years
that I've been at "Allure"--
so right before I started,
I created a presentation
for my bosses to say,
this is what I would
want to do with the brand.
And obviously, you
start out having a plan,
and things evolve over time.
I think if I looked back
at that presentation now,
a lot of things would
have changed from it.
But one of the things that was
core to that mission even back
then was diversity.
So it's crazy actually
to think about
that 3 and 1/2 years ago, there
was like hardly any diversity
when it came to
magazine covers, when
it came to models on
runways, and actually, we've
come so far since then.
But I think back
three years ago,
it was still considered to
be kind of a quote, unquote,
"risk" to put a person
of color on the cover.
I'd have to look
back at the numbers,
but I would guess
that on average,
if you looked at the
normal magazine cover,
it was maybe average to have
about two people of color
on a cover in a year.
Last year alone, I think
more than half of our covers
were people of color.
But it's also not just doing
diversity for diversity's sake.
I think that now, we've moved
on to this space of looking
at what it means as a story, but
also making sure that diversity
is just woven into
everything that we do
and that it doesn't
feel heavy handed.
I think that the thing that
we never want to happen
is have someone feel
like it's exploitative
or that we're just doing it
to get the pat on the back.
And also thinking about
what is diversity, right?
I think that as an
Asian-American woman,
I think of diversity
first and foremost
from a gender perspective, but
also from race and ethnicity.
But when it comes
to beauty, I think
there are still a lot of
underserved communities
that deal with
body type, ageism.
We, in 2017, famously banned the
term anti-aging from "Allure"
forever, and it actually became
just this global phenomenon
where people around the
world were talking about it.
I actually read
something that in the UK,
someone had put
forward a referendum
to ban anti-aging from the UK
because they read our story.
So I feel like
there is something
through diversity
and inclusion that we
can do that's really important
and kind of beyond just making
people feel good
about themselves.
I think that--
I have two kids, so for my
son and also my daughter,
I think it's really cool--
the fact that they
can watch movies,
that they can look
at magazine covers,
that they can look at photos
of people who look like them,
and it's not necessarily that
this image of beauty that's
portrayed by the media or
pop culture or anything else
is just this one
super narrow view.
So yeah, I think diversity--
it's been very, very
important to me.
We, last year, also--
you mentioned the
Gemma Chan cover.
Last year for June,
we had our hair issue.
So we were trying to think about
who we would have on the cover.
So it's always this
big discussion.
We usually have
boards up and stuff
about looking at different
celebrities and models of who
is having a moment right now.
So we decided to choose
three Asian models,
and we-- it still was this
beautiful hair moment.
We had one with
bright pink hair,
we had one with black hair,
and one with platinum hair.
But putting three Asian
models on the cover--
it was sort of this
statement without being too
beat people over the head
of it about tokenism,
because normally, if you look at
an advertisement or a magazine
cover where they talk
about it being diverse,
there is usually, let's say,
five white models and then
one person of color.
So for us, we were
like, we're going
to give these three Asian
models their own cover.
It went crazy out in the
world of social media.
Chrissy Teigen tweeted
about it and stuff.
And so I wrote my
editor's letter about--
after we decided to
do that, I actually
started looking into
how many Asian women had
been on the cover of "Allure"
in the past 28 years.
So in the past 28 years--
and I want to say it
was like 327 covers--
there had only been
two Asian women.
The first was Lucy
Liu over 10 years ago,
and then Olivia Munn.
So in this one issue
of "Allure" where
we had the three Asian
women on the cover,
we actually had more
Asian representation
than in the entire
28 year history.
So that's just "Allure," and I
think for the entire industry,
it's important for all
of us, when we can,
to be showing that these
things can be successful
and showing that--
just what it looks
like, because I
think that the people who
are at the helm of some
of the other brands--
they don't know what it is
until they actually see it.
And the thing that I
find kind of alarming--
I talk a lot about diversity
in a lot of panels and stuff,
and I think that there
are a lot of people
who think that we're
good, that we're like,
oh, the beauty and fashion
industry is so diverse now.
And I'm like, we
are so not there.
I think that people very
much still see it as like--
they've got one
sort of-- they've
got like a light
skinned black girl,
and then they go,
tick, like, ding.
We can click that off.
And I just feel like
there's so much more to do
and so much more to
start the conversation.
SPEAKER: Thank you
for providing a voice
to a lot of communities that
haven't seen representation.
So I really appreciate that.
MICHELLE LEE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Beyond just disrupting
covers and narratives
that you tell in "Allure,"
I'm curious to know,
from your POV, what
are some areas that
are ripe for disruption in
the beauty industry today?
MICHELLE LEE: So many.
How many of you work in the
beauty industry right now?
Because I feel like there
were some of you who
had beauty clients, right?
OK.
So beauty is so
exciting right now.
I don't have to tell
you guys who work in it.
I do think, though, in the
world of sustainability,
I actually think that there's a
lot of interesting conversation
happening right now, and
partly because if you think
about beauty and personal
care, how much waste there is,
not only just on the
consumer portion of things.
Like we talk about
this all the time
because us testing 10,000
products in a three month
period for Best of Beauty--
imagine how much just
packaging waste we get.
And it tends to be that the more
expensive brands, let's say,
in skin care--
we always equate it to
like a Russian doll where
it's like you get this
little tiny cream,
but it's inside 10
boxes that you have
to kind of open up like this.
There's a lot of waste
within that process,
but then also within
manufacturing.
So I actually think,
and I've started
to see some movement in
this, too, of some startups
and stuff who are doing
things packaging free.
I think Lush does some really
interesting things, also
in terms of bath bombs.
If you think about them, there's
no packaging waste, whatsoever.
So I think that some of the
new things that I've just
been seeing hitting my
desk have been more related
to the actual delivery of
things, as opposed to even--
there's still innovation
happening with skin care
ingredients and with new
makeup colors and everything,
but in a way, that's almost
like side stuff right now,
and the really cool
things are actually
happening in the
distribution of products,
in personalization,
and also in how
to create these things in
a more sustainable way.
SPEAKER: Is there
a favorite brand
that you see doing this that
our audience should be aware of?
MICHELLE LEE: Like
I said, I think
Lush is really interesting.
There was this brand, which--
I'm going to butcher
the name of the brand,
so I'm not even going to say it,
but this founder-- and it's not
a big company, whatsoever, yet.
But she came to visit
me, and it was that--
her thought process was so smart
because she basically had--
it was like a little bamboo
round box that just swivels,
and she called them--
I think it was like bath stones.
No, no, I'm sorry.
Body stones.
So basically, this woman
who was the founder--
she started out in finance, but
then she went to pastry school.
So she learned how to make
chocolates and everything.
So using the same methods of
how she would make chocolates,
she decided that she wanted
to make body care products.
So rather than having-- if you
think about the lotion bottles
that you have at home,
right, what do you?
You hopefully recycle them,
but then you just toss them,
and it's like a lot of waste.
For her, she was like, if
I create these body stones,
it's basically just, you
rub it onto your body,
and then the heat from
your skin melts it
and it's basically
zero waste, whatsoever.
I don't know how big her
company is going to be,
but I thought that the
thought process behind it
was really innovative,
and I think
that the more people who are
doing those types of things,
the larger companies are
also going to follow suit.
SPEAKER: I like this.
Environmental,
sustainable-- probably
where the direction of
the world needs to go.
So I'm kind of curious.
Because we live
here in New York,
it's definitely a mecca for
all sorts of beauty treatments
and beauty innovation.
What are some must
tries in New York City?
MICHELLE LEE: Oh my gosh.
I've tried so many.
I thought about
this a lot because I
think as part of my job--
a very fun part of my job--
we get to try a lot of
different treatments.
So I recently, which we were
just talking about before,
had brow microblading.
I don't know if you guys
all know what that is,
but it's basically
little tattoos
that look like hairs,
so you don't have to do
your brows anymore every day.
Fascinating.
Highly, highly recommend it.
The other thing, too, is that
I think that for a long time,
people either
believed in facials
or they didn't
believe in facials.
I think I knew a lot of
people who thought, well,
facials are just kind of BS.
Like they basically just put a
lot of products on your face,
and you could do that at
home and not pay $300.
Today, though, I think
the modern facials
are really cool because they mix
technology also with products.
There are a couple of really
great facials in the city.
I love Joanna Vargas.
There's Dr. David Colbert,
who-- he recently, I
want to say within the past
couple of years, launched
a whole secondary practice.
So his first practice was the
New York dermatological center,
and then now, he has
a whole other floor
of this building that's all
surrounding technology and skin
care and just general beauty.
So he has things like
red light LED beds--
very, very cool stuff.
And then the other thing I
would highly recommend, too,
for anyone who's very into
skin care, is microneedling.
Do you guys all
know what that is?
OK.
So microneedling, you probably
see on Instagram and stuff
of those at-home
tools where it looks
sort of like a little
roller, and those are fine.
But I think if you go to get
professional microneedling,
I highly, highly believe
in it, where again,
it's sort of this merger
of technology and skin care
and everything else where the
thought process behind it is
basically-- if you've ever had a
laser treatment, it's similar--
that if you get a
little cut on your skin,
our skin is miraculous
because it can heal itself.
So it's sort of a
similar situation
of where it's creating
these little micro-injuries
in your skin that
then heal themselves,
and then they're producing
more collagen. That one, I
truly, truly believe in.
You may have seen some
of the scary photos
online of the vampire facial.
That's a part of microneedling
where they do something called
PRP, which is
Platelet Rich Plasma,
and they basically spin
your blood in a centrifuge,
and then after they
do microneedling,
they put that all
over your face.
It looks crazy, but
it really does work.
SPEAKER: Well I got to chat
with Michelle prior to this
and saw her very up close,
and her skin looks great.
So maybe I'll have to take
some of your recommendations
and go for this.
So at Google, I've
had the pleasure
of working with a lot of
different types of people,
and one person who's very
dear to me who sits next to me
is a drag queen on the weekends
and sometimes on nights.
So I'm really curious
about this question here.
Beauty, historically,
has primarily
been focused on women, but
when I've covered the beauty
industry within Google, the big
trend I see is year over year,
we see men's grooming
skyrocketing exponentially.
And mainstream culture has
also increasingly embraced
male-identified makeup
influencers in shows
like "RuPaul's Drag Race."
So how do you see this
impacting change over time?
And what do you expect in this
space in the coming years?
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah.
Oh, I think for sure in
the past year and a half,
I would say, the whole--
it sounds weird to
even call it a trend,
but the whole movement
of genderless beauty
has really taken off.
I tend to think that in
the next couple of years,
especially among the
younger generation,
they're not going to
see gender anymore,
when it comes to beauty.
My daughter is 10, and all of
her friends went crazy for--
there was like the James Charles
palette over the holidays.
They all wanted this
James Charles palette.
I think that genderless beauty
is a really important trend.
There's been a lot of
discussion about male grooming
in the past five years, though.
I think that when I
talk to companies,
they haven't really
seen like a huge--
there's always been this
feeling of men's grooming
is going to really take off,
really going to take off.
And I think that if we
looked at it on a chart,
I'm sure that it
has kind of gone up.
I don't know that there's going
to be like a huge boom in it,
though, that we're feeling yet.
I actually think that
there's still a huge--
just looking at
America, there's still
a huge, huge group of
people who don't do
any type of beauty whatsoever.
I think Olay had done some
study a couple years ago that
found that the vast
majority of people
don't even wash their faces.
So even to capture 1%
of those people who
don't wash their faces, like
that's still a huge number.
So I think that if I
were a beauty brand,
I would definitely be
looking at like some
of the low-hanging fruit
of like can we just
get people to wash their faces?
But, yeah, I think that in
general, like drag makeup,
frankly, has been probably the
biggest catalyst for pushing
makeup in general,
because if you look
at every big-- or not every.
If you look at most big
beauty influencers right now,
everyone is kind of doing
a form of drag makeup.
Contouring, you know, like
really amazing, amazing
blending of like eye shadows--
a lot of that really originates
from the drag community.
So I think that,
frankly, there's
a lot of people who
don't realize that.
But I do think that
a lot of people
do realize that there is
that, the emphasis of it,
and also just
appreciate the artistry.
SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
So "Allure" has also been
able to expand the brand
with efforts like the
Best of Beauty seal
that you see in a lot of stores,
as well as the "Allure" Beauty
Subscription Box.
So why do you think
these have been
so successful for the company?
And how important
is it for brands
that have had more traditional
approaches to innovate,
to grow?
MICHELLE LEE: Yep.
Well, I think this one goes
back to what I was saying before
about getting people to
understand that we're not just
a media brand, and
we truly are a brand.
I completely nerd
out when it comes
to business and technology.
Like I love talking
about those things.
So the fact that as
an editor-in-chief
I can actually work
on consumer products
is really exciting to me.
I think it's important
for us, and the reason
it's been successful has been we
do have these 28 years of trust
that "Allure" has built up.
I think everything
that we do when
it comes to consumer
products, and events,
and other things is
kind of still built
on this overall
trust and authority
of us being that
brand that if it's
anything related to beauty, you
should trust our word on it.
Like we want to be the first
and last word on any beauty
trend, on what the
best products are.
And if you think about like
the "Allure" Beauty Box,
it's a monthly
subscription that you get.
And so what makes ours
different from some
of the other ones
on the market is
that it's all editor curated.
So it's sort of
like getting a box
from me, where we would write
little reviews about here's
what you should like
about this product.
Here's how you can use it.
This worked for this skin
tone, not for this skin tone.
We actually had an editor from
"Allure" Korea visit recently.
And she brought me two
boxes, like about this big,
like really big, filled
with Korean beauty products
that you can't buy here.
And she very nicely wrote like
little handwritten Post-it
notes on every
single one of them.
And it's hard to get
me excited about things
now because we see
so many products.
But I was so excited to get
these products because it
was hand-curated by her,
where she was like, these are
the products that I
know that Michelle
is going to get excited about
and that she's going to love.
So I think that,
in the ideal case,
is really what the
"Allure" Beauty Box should
be, that for you at home, if
you're a fan of "Allure" on any
of the other platforms,
or maybe not,
you feel like you're
getting something
that is straight
from the editors
that we've picked for you.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
So this question-- our
audience today, no surprise,
skews heavily towards women.
So I'd like to ask this
question on their behalf, right?
You have a very
powerful position
at determining the
voice of "Allure"
and what gets disseminated
to your readers, right?
So for a lot of the
women in this room
who do envision themselves
in a leadership position one
day, what are the habits and
behaviors that you adopted
over the years that
helped propel you
to where you are today?
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, out of
curiosity, as a show of hands,
how many of you manage people?
OK, so a bunch of you.
I think, for me, the biggest
lesson that I had to learn
was about management.
And I'm not sure how
things are at Google.
Do you guys have like
management training here?
SPEAKER: Yes.
MICHELLE LEE: You do, OK.
SPEAKER: I think when you get
promoted to a certain level,
[INAUDIBLE].
MICHELLE LEE: Got it.
So typically, in media,
there's no such-- well,
I mean, there's some, I
guess, management training.
But it's not
necessarily something
that people have to go
through or always go through.
So the weird thing
about when you
start to climb the
ladder within media,
often you start as an assistant.
There used to be sort
of like this path.
You become an assistant
editor, an associate editor,
senior editor, dah dah dah.
The further you go up, suddenly
you're managing people.
And then it becomes
this weird thing.
And especially if you're
a young manager, for me,
it was a hard
transition of where
you go from being people's
friend and colleague
to suddenly you're
managing people.
And I think the
hardest thing for me--
and as I've talked to other
women who are managers, too--
one of the hardest things
is this distinction
between being liked
and being respected
and not confusing those two,
because they are different.
And I think that for a
long time in the earlier
part of my career, I only
cared about being liked.
And it would hurt my feelings
if I felt like I wasn't liked.
The difference now, I think,
is that along the way--
and my husband's actually here,
and he was the one who sort
of like drove this
home with me--
it's more important
to be respected.
And if you have the
respect of your team,
they're also going
to like you, too.
So I think that what happens
a lot sometimes with women,
I think, in particular is that
you can get kind of frozen
in decision-making if you
try and make everyone happy.
So if you're trying to
make everyone happy,
you're going to
make no one happy.
I very much learned-- so
Anna Wintour is my boss.
And I very much
learned a lot from her
in terms of decision-making.
People always talk about she
is the most efficient woman
in the world.
I don't know how she does all
of her meetings every day.
But I have definitely
noticed that if there's
a meeting with her, and
it's set for half an hour,
it's done in about 10 minutes.
So I've started to-- whoop--
I've started to do that
also, and understanding
just how much more
efficient I can
be with my time, how
much more efficient
I can be with decision-making,
not sitting on decisions all
the time and being like, what
do you think, what do you think?
Like, obviously, I want
to hear people's opinions.
But I think there comes
a time where you just
have to kind of pull the
trigger and do something.
So, yeah, I think
learning management has
been a really big thing for me.
What was the rest
of your question?
I feel like I had
another point about that.
SPEAKER: The rest
of my question was
related to around other
strategies or habits--
MICHELLE LEE: Right.
SPEAKER: --that
you might have had,
or any books or trainings that
you might have attended that
could be shareable
with the audience.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah,
I think the big thing
for me was understanding
that being a good manager
and leadership is all
about being different, too.
I don't know if it's something
about being Asian-American also
maybe, but I think that--
I've definitely thought
about this a lot,
that when I was younger, I
just wanted to assimilate.
So I grew up in a
very not-diverse town.
And so my whole MO back then
was be like everyone else.
I just want to fit in and
be like everyone else.
And weirdly, in the
beginning of my career,
I think that I kind of took
that same approach, where I was
like, I would work in a job.
And I was like, I just want
to be like everyone else
and fit in.
So any of my ideas
that I had, I didn't
want to do anything that
was too weird because I just
want to fit in, when
actually, probably
like at the halfway
point of my career,
I realized that I was doing
things completely wrong.
And here at Google,
I think you guys
have a completely different
approach on things,
where it is about standing
out and having ideas.
In certain worlds of media,
especially in fashion media,
it was not that way whatsoever.
But I always-- the advice
that I give to people now
is stand out.
Be weird.
Have kind of weird ideas.
It truly is that thing that I
don't think like 10 years ago,
because I was so sort of
stuck in this mindset of just
fitting in, I don't
think that I would
have gotten to where I am
now if I didn't start to take
big risks, take big chances.
And some of that comes
with being a leader
and being given the
opportunity to do that.
I'm lucky in that, like,
my bosses have given me
that opportunity and the
runway to be like, it's OK.
Go ahead.
They haven't said,
make mistakes,
but they've said,
take big risks.
And I took that as make
mistakes sometimes.
But I think it's
important to stand out.
Like I always talk about
people in our office
who I call them
the quiet warriors.
And that used to be me, where
I had this feeling that if you
just put your head down and like
work, work, work, work, work,
you're there 12 hours
a day, and you're
going to prove to your boss
that you are the hardest
worker there.
In some cases that works.
But I will say,
like the people who
are better about
promoting themselves,
they're good at
presenting in meetings,
they have some of
those softer skills,
too, it is so important.
And I think, because of
like looking at my kids now,
I think, nowadays they teach
kids like better presenting
skills, how to do
things like that more,
to think outside the box.
But it very much was something
that I had to learn a lot.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
So I would love to
know, what is it
like to work for Anna Wintour?
MICHELLE LEE: It's amazing.
Like I said, I have
learned so much from her.
So do you guys
all know Eva Chen?
OK, so Eva, my very first
day when I came to work
at "Allure," and it was actually
my fourth time working at Condé
Nast.
But becoming an editor-in-chief
at "Allure" is a big deal.
So I live in New Jersey.
And I was driving into
work my first day.
So Eva was like, call me,
because I'll give you,
like, you know, advice
about how to do things.
So she was the one
who first said to me,
like, you're not going to have
a lot of small talk with Anna.
But it's not because
she doesn't want to.
It's that she is so busy.
And she is the most
efficient woman in the world.
So in emails, everything else,
you just get to the point.
So again, like sometimes
I'm someone who
I will write a lot in an email.
But with her, I just know
to keep it short and sweet.
And I think that
because of those things,
and understanding
that in a meeting
you have to just get your
point out right away,
I actually feel like I've
learned so much from that.
And I've learned a
lot from watching her.
Her personality
and my personality
are not necessarily
exactly the same.
And I don't think that
that's necessarily, like,
what she's looking for either.
But I have learned so
much just about dealing
with people, management, and
getting straight to the point.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
So as a very public
face of "Allure,"
what are three values that you
abide by or causes that you
work on outside of "Allure"?
MICHELLE LEE: Ooh, causes.
Well, I guess to answer
your first question,
I guess like qualities--
I feel like there is a feeling
of respect that, especially
working at a brand that's within
the fashion and beauty space,
I think that the stereotype,
I guess, of working in fashion
was that it was very bitchy.
And like people are mean
and backbiting and stuff.
And, yes, it does exist
in certain places.
I think for me, though, I have
always spent my entire career
with this kind of dumb
belief sometimes, I guess,
of where people should
be happy at work.
And like I am just such
a huge believer in it,
where people have
given me advice
before about like you need
to go, like, Machiavellian
on this person, and
do this, dah dah.
I'm just a huge believer that
like if I just go like that,
I do things with respect,
and like trust people,
everything tends to
kind of work out fine.
I think in terms of causes
that I'm really interested in,
so last week I was at a
gala for Apex for Youth.
Have you ever heard of this?
SPEAKER: Mm-hm, yes.
MICHELLE LEE: So Apex
for Youth is actually
this great Asian-American
organization here in the city.
And I have learned
so much from them,
because I actually had
no idea until getting
involved with them that
Asian-Americans actually
have the highest poverty
rate here in the city.
There are crazy statistics about
how I think Asian-Americans
make up 13% of the
population here in the city
but only get about
1% of the resources.
There are a ton of kids who--
I don't remember
the exact stats,
but it's like a lot of them
are the only one who speaks
English in their household.
Like a lot of them
drop out of school.
So I feel like in
the past three years,
I've definitely gotten
involved in that quite a bit.
And like I said, diversity
efforts in general,
I think because of
everything that we've
done at "Allure" in terms of
really promoting diversity,
it is absolutely
the topic that I
go out and talk about the most.
And also the thing I
find really interesting
is the more sort of
internal part of it, too.
Like I've met with a lot
of diversity-and-inclusion
directors for other
companies that we normally
don't work with, like other,
like, consumer electronics
and stuff like that.
And I'm always
fascinated to hear
about what people are doing.
I met with someone
from, I want to say
it was like Samsung and
another company also.
And they were talking
about how they've actually
started-- they've
stopped using the terms
diversity and inclusion.
And now internally they
just say belonging.
And they explained to me about
how belonging is different.
And I don't know.
I'm just finding it
really fascinating
watching what's happening to the
world in this super short span
of time.
SPEAKER: So if you
weren't editor-in-chief
of "Allure," what else
would be your dream job?
MICHELLE LEE: Well,
I used to always say
when I was way too old to say
this, when people would say,
what do you want to be when you
grow up, I always said a baker.
[CHUCKLES]
I think when I was a little
kid, I really just enjoyed
the fantasy of being a baker.
And I thought I could
just wear the hat
and like have fun all the time.
I was this weird
kid who, up until I
was a sophomore in
college, I really
didn't know what I wanted to do.
People ask me all
the time, like did
you know when you were a
little kid that you wanted
to be an editor-in-chief?
Not at all.
I think once I chose
journalism, everything
ended up falling into place.
And then you look
back on your life,
and everything
sort of made sense.
I think that if I-- as I was
mentioning to you before,
I'm obsessed with food.
So I would either want to--
I don't think I would actually
want to cook or bake, though.
My dream job is really to
have, like, a travel show,
where I just go around
and travel and eat.
[CHUCKLES]
SPEAKER: Is there a favorite
restaurant in New York
or in the world?
MICHELLE LEE: OK,
so in the world,
we-- actually, my whole
family went to Europe,
and we stayed for like a
couple of weeks last year.
And we went to
Frenchie in Paris.
And it was one of those
things where it was just
an amazing experience.
And like I love, love,
love traveling and eating.
I also spent two weeks in
Japan this past summer.
And it's hard to even say like
what my favorite restaurant was
there.
I think it's more of
the experience of going.
And some of my favorite
meals-- this sounds so great--
were actually just like,
you know, just stops
and having like a little
like rice bowl or something.
A lot of times, I
feel like it's just
the overall experience of it.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
Well, actually, at this time--
thank you, Michelle--
we're going
to open the floor
for any questions
that folks may
have for Michelle.
So we do have two mics
on the right and left.
And feel free to ask a
question if you have any.
MICHELLE LEE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So my question is,
you mentioned that your--
one of your objectives was
to turn "Allure" from being
a magazine into a brand.
So I was wondering, for the
content that is traditionally
delivered through the
magazine, like the articles
and the interviews, like whether
that will kind of-- the idea
is for it to continue
to go through that,
or if like some of that will
be moved on to other platforms,
and like what the role of the
magazine will be in the future?
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, no,
it's a great question.
I think that for
us, the magazine
is still a really important
part of who we are.
The great thing about--
I mean, you guys all know.
Like the media world right
now, it's like this, right?
You hear about every
week practically
there's some new website
going under, or being sold,
or like a magazine is
going out of print.
I think for us, though,
what's great is that we're
part of the beauty world.
And the beauty world is one
of the only growing sectors
right now, especially
within retail,
which I know you work in, too.
Like, you know,
beauty has really
been the one that's just sort
of like bucking all the trends.
Whereas like other
brick-and-mortar stores
are going out of business,
the Sephoras, and Ultas,
and Credo Beauties,
and everything,
like they're all
taking off like crazy.
It's sort of the same thing
with us for print, too.
I think that print, there is
such an interest in beauty
right now that we're very
lucky in that it's really
been like kind of
growing and stable.
In terms of like platforms,
though, I actually
think that they're
such different beasts.
I always talk about
that with digital media,
it's very much a sort of
like lean-forward experience,
where you're reading
kind of quicker articles.
You're watching videos
and other things.
Still, to me, the print
experience is very lean-back.
It's very much like you
always see people on airplanes
and like at the
beach and everything.
It's that time that you get to
just sort of like lean back.
And it's such a
different experience.
So I think that when we
think about creating content
in that way, too, we
think about the magazine
as that place where we can
do some more long reads.
There's more
investigative journalism.
There's more reporting there.
There's more just
beautiful, big photography.
And the other thing
that I think is still
very important on so many
different levels is the cover.
So I always say to people that
a magazine cover still matters.
And you probably have
all seen that a lot
of digital, native
brands are starting
to do now digital
covers, because there's
something about when you
pop that logo on a photo,
it just means something.
I think it sort of, it's like
the original form of curation,
that it's saying,
this is the person,
this is the story that you
should really pay attention to.
So in terms of like
celebrities, everyone else,
like that cover
still really matters.
When we put Helen
Mirren on our cover
when we banned the
term anti-aging,
we could have done that
as a smaller story online.
But the fact that we
made it a cover story
and shot her for the cover had
so much more impact than that.
So I definitely the magazine
is really important.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I've noticed this
happening a lot recently,
where a lot of women
in their 20s and 30s
are starting to
think about Botox.
And I'm just curious,
your thoughts on that,
the health risks,
and again, just kind
of going back to
that term anti-aging,
and what kind of that means with
Botox coming into play so early
on.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah,
well, it's funny
because after we
banned anti-aging,
I think some people
took it as, does that
mean that you guys are going
to stop talking about Botox,
you're going to stop
doing things on skin care?
I think for us, that was
totally not our intention.
Like, for us, we are
very much whatever
you want to do that makes
you happy is awesome.
I think that for people
in their 20s and 30s
who want to try Botox,
I think why not, right?
I think that anything
that makes you happy,
as long as it's something that's
actually driven by you and not
by society saying,
this is what we think
you need to do
because, uh-oh, you're
getting some little fine lines
and wrinkles under there.
I think that there is--
I would say in your
20s and 30s, though,
there's other skin care that
can probably do similar things
at this point.
Like I said, microneedling
is one of them.
Definitely I've talked
to other people who
because they don't want to do, I
don't know, four times of Botox
a year, they're kind of willing
to try other things first.
That would be my suggestion
is that a lot of it, frankly,
in terms of like early
aging, is sun damage.
I know there's been
a lot of like talk
about the danger
of sunscreen now.
But even just honestly
wearing a hat,
or like when you
go to the beach,
going under shade sometimes.
Like seriously,
like anyone who's
seen those, the images of
like sun damage on skin,
it is a real thing.
When you go to Asia,
like every woman
is wearing like a big hat.
She's got an umbrella
on a sunny day.
Like we need to start
taking more care--
maybe not that far, but--
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When I
think of "Allure,"
I always think industry
leader and, like, authentic.
And whether it's in terms of
your diverse [INAUDIBLE] covers
or the Best of Beauty
seal that you provide,
one problem that I perceive
in the social media beauty
industry right now is
these influencer-led
direct-to-consumer brands, where
a lot of the content that I'm
seeing today are ads by
DTC beauty companies, where
someone or the other
has a really glorious,
authentic review of the brand.
And that, in itself,
is the ad, right?
There is no other professionally
shot post or anything.
I find that quite misleading
and also potentially dangerous.
So as an industry
leader, do you feel
like "Allure" has a
responsibility or a role
to play to rectify
the situation here?
MICHELLE LEE: I think that
it would probably take more
than us to rectify
the situation,
because you mentioned like diet
products in particular, right?
AUDIENCE: Diet and,
in general, all sorts
of corrective measures
in the beauty space.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Whether
it's teeth whitening,
teeth straightening,
pores, so on and so forth.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, I do think
that we have the authority
to do that.
I think that, again, like the
whole anti-aging thing really
changed my viewpoint on how
we look at what our role is,
that actually as the industry
leader, by us saying--
like in my Editor's
Letter of that issue,
I did a call to the
entire industry,
saying, we call on you guys
to join us in this change.
And I've thought about--
this is sort of off the record.
But I've thought about
doing something similar
with sustainability, too,
that if us as a leader--
like I don't think that a
beauty brand could say, hey,
beauty industry, we want
you guys to join us.
It's different coming from them.
I think coming from
"Allure" to say,
we're going to take this huge
step, we want you to join us,
I think it does mean something.
And similarly,
with diet products
and also just sort of like
the ads and everything,
I think it's a huge problem.
I am hopeful that
consumers can kind of
see through those things.
But I do wonder, ,
like what it's doing.
And I, again, like think
about my son is 14.
So I think for
14-year-olds in particular,
especially like
with girls, there's
so much that's targeted to
them that they don't fully
understand yet
what's like sponsored
and what's not sponsored.
In terms of what we
could do about it,
I don't think that it's
something that I've necessarily
thought about before.
But do you know Jameela Jamil?
So, right, so she's been like
so outspoken as one person,
saying, you guys,
stop doing this.
So when I do look at
someone like her--
and we actually, we featured
her as part of that, too--
like I feel like
she is someone who's
shown that even us
just like one person
you can have an impact on that.
So I don't know how to
answer it necessarily,
because I don't think that we're
doing anything specifically
related to that.
I do think it's an issue.
And at least on our own
platforms, like we--
one of the big questions that I
always got when I first started
was, how do you plan to compete
with influencers, right?
Because when people think
about the beauty world, they do
think about influencers now.
There's a lot of brands who
are paying them a lot of money.
A lot of them have
very big audiences.
I think that we're such
a different animal.
And I think that we
can actually co-exist.
The big thing with
us, though, and which
I think some of the
bigger influencers
also are starting to adopt
some of these methods,
is don't accept
money for something
that you don't believe in.
I think that for some of
the smaller influencers,
or the ones who are just focused
on getting money probably,
they maybe don't
understand that.
But I always say to our
team, like there is no one,
there's no brand who
can pay me to say
that a product is the best.
There's no brand that can pay
me to say I like a product,
that I use a product
all the time.
We definitely do branded
and sponsored posts.
But I think there's a way
to do things that you still
maintain your credibility.
AUDIENCE: Have you--
just a follow-up to that,
have you thought of like having
a certification for influencers
in place, sort of saying that
these are the guidelines that
influencers should
follow to be authentic,
and here's a list of
influencers that "Allure"
is working with who meet
these guidelines for brands,
small and large,
to really follow,
and for consumers to also
know that if it's coming from
an "Allure"-certified
influencer, I am like--
MICHELLE LEE: That's
actually a really great idea.
We've thought about
similar things of,
right now our Best
of Beauty awards
are really just for products.
So we have thought before
about do we, at some point,
expand those awards to
include people, other things?
That's a great idea, though.
AUDIENCE: I'd love to hear
more about your thoughts
on how "Allure" as a brand with
20-plus years of reputation
as beauty experts can coexist
with this influx of beauty
influencers and people
on YouTube, Instagram,
Facebook, and social media
who, in their own way,
people have been coming
to them perhaps because
of a history of a lack
of diversity in print
and in media.
And YouTube, anyone
can be an influencer,
and you can find someone who
really matches you, or works
for, you know, your look,
your color, et cetera.
And so, yeah, I'd love
to hear more about how
you think about
coexisting in that space
and not thinking about that
as kind of cannibalizing.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, I
think it's two things.
One, I see what our biggest
differentiating factor is,
is expertise.
So it's not only that we're
this collective of editors
who literally see every single
product, we go to every show,
we see every trend before
products even come out.
So we have this built-in
expertise among our staff.
But then we also have the
expertise of all the experts
who we talk to.
So dermatologists, plastic
surgeons, cosmetic chemists,
medical doctors--
you know, whoever
else, and we're
talking to the best of
the best in the world.
I think with influencers,
with most of them
it comes from a place
of personal experience.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
I definitely want, when I'm
looking at a product to buy
or something else, I
want to hear the person's
personal experience.
But I think there's
also something
really valuable with having
the science behind things,
the broader scope of things,
understanding that actually
that ingredient doesn't
mix well with that one,
and you shouldn't use that.
So I think that where
we have kind of like
carved out a really
great niche for ourself
has been that feeling of
expertise and authority.
But then the other
thing was, too,
when I started at
"Allure," I always say
like I really didn't know
a lot of the editors.
I think now with social
media and everything,
like I follow a lot of editors.
I feel like the dictate
at "Allure" was very much,
we write from the
royal we, right?
You're writing as
"Allure" the brand.
You're not "Allure."
You're not Jenny Bailly, who's
our executive beauty director.
You're not writing
from Jenny's voice.
You're writing from
the "Allure" voice.
I very much wanted to
tear down those walls,
because I do think that beauty
is personal, that as you were
saying before about
like diversity,
like because of YouTube and
social media and everything
else, you do kind of want
to connect to somebody
and understand, OK, this
person has hair like mine.
This person has
dry skin like mine.
So I very much wanted to make
sure that people understood
who is behind the brand, too.
So in the "Allure" Beauty
Box, for example, we actually
just started doing this, where
the reviews in our little mini
magazine that we put in each box
used to be written in the royal
we, where it would just be
sort of the "Allure" voice.
But we've actually now started
putting little editor photos
with each of them.
And it's written from
that first person.
So you understand that,
like, if Gabby did a review,
Gabby is talking about it from
her own personal experience
as an editor and as an expert.
But also, you can
understand, oh, OK, great,
she's just like me.
You know, I understand that
this is her personal experience.
So I feel like it's
such a different thing.
And we do work with
some influencers, too.
I think for a long
time, there were
editors who kind of didn't
really like influencers.
They thought like, oh, who
are these people sitting
front row at Fashion
Week and blah blah blah?
I actually have a
totally different belief.
I think that there are
great ones out there
who we can work with.
We've done really great
partnerships with people
before.
And it can be sort of this,
like, mutually beneficial
thing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for talking
about the new brands coming
in to the cosmetics space
for gender inclusivity.
I guess my question
is, as an editor,
when you're thinking about
an article on those types
of brands or items to put
in an "Allure" box, what
do you think makes one brand
better than another, other
than like an authentic brand
message around inclusion?
Just like what's the difference
between formulation and--
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --colors for--
MICHELLE LEE: It's a lot.
I will tell you,
because I'm heavily
in testing right now for
Best of Beauty awards,
I'm shocked sometimes by how
many bad products there are.
Like I think that as we're
testing these like thousands
and thousands of products, it
actually makes me really sad
that people spend
money on products
that are just not good.
So I think instantly, we're
able to really determine quickly
like what's bad, right?
But then let's
say if you're left
with like 20 eyeliners or
something that you're like,
OK, these are really good,
it's a lot of testing.
If it's skin care, we
go to a lot of experts,
and we talk about, you
know, it's not necessarily
the ingredients.
But it's also looking at
the amounts of ingredients,
because sometimes
people think like, oh,
if it's 100% hyaluronic
acid, it must be better.
Actually, that's not true.
Like if you talk to a chemist,
and they're like, actually,
the optimal percentage
is going to be this,
we get very, very nerdy about
some of these ingredient
things.
So I think it's a lot of
research with those things.
And also, like the
biggest thing is,
I think you mentioned
the word authenticity.
Fenty Beauty obviously
had a big year,
like big couple of years
where they really did
disrupt the beauty industry.
When they came out
of the gate and they
had those 40 shades
of foundation,
it was a huge statement.
There were other brands
at the time, though, who
said, well, that's nothing new.
We started out, and we had
a diverse shade range also.
But I think what was
different about Fenty
was that the diversity
message wasn't just,
here's 40 colors
on our Instagram.
The diversity-and-inclusion
message
was woven through every
single thing that they did.
So every single photo, every
video, everything that they do,
it's all interwoven in that.
And I think that nowadays,
the consumer is kind of savvy.
And they understand that--
like for those six to eight
months after Fenty came out,
there were a ton of
other brands who were
like, we now have 40 shades.
We now have 40 shades.
And that's great.
And I think it's been
an amazing movement.
But I do think that
the consumer can
kind of tell when there's
like a true authenticity
behind things.
And brands have to be able
to follow through on it,
too, because I think one
of the big complaints
has been even though a brand
will say they have 40 shades,
if you then go to the
store, they actually
don't stock the darker shades.
So it does come in.
People talk, right?
Like influencers talk.
Reviews talk.
People will understand pretty
quickly if you are not really
the real deal.
AUDIENCE: I've worked here as
a product marketer and a brand
marketer.
And my line of work
has me thinking
a lot about the relationship
between dark skin
and technology these days.
From a machine-learning
perspective,
from a camera-vision
perspective, how do you--
we've seen that manufacturers
in different parts of the world
will sometimes express or
build in cultural preference
into the way that
technology works.
So in India, you
see skin lightening.
In China, you see
skin whitening.
How do you deal with the
relationship between trend
and cultural preference
and morality, I guess,
and kind of what
is a good standard?
MICHELLE LEE: My
take on it is that I
think that for people in a
position of authority of mine,
let's say, in media, I
think that morality is key.
I think that
sometimes, for example,
we've done covers in the past
where I think because diversity
has been such an
important thing to me
and to the brand,
which if you looked
at the newsstand sales of that
issue, it wasn't a big winner.
At the same time, I kind
of don't care, right?
I actually think that as a
larger mission, you know,
magazine sales used
to always be like what
are your newsstand sales?
And that drove what
was the success
or the failure of anything.
I think that I look at it
now as success is overall
what we're doing, how we're
growing, but also what
we're doing with society and
how we're changing things.
When I look back at how--
I actually really do
think that we've pushed
the needle in a lot of ways.
I think just even from my
own personal experience,
I think that the
morality part of it
is always going to be key.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a quick follow-up?
So if your back is
against the wall,
and you have to justify
a decision like that,
how does that conversation
go [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHELLE LEE: I'm very
lucky, like I said,
in that my bosses,
diversity for them
is such a core mission, too.
I have never had a problem
with pushing forward anything.
So I'm actually on the Diversity
Council of our company as well.
And I think that,
unfortunately, I
do know it's not like
that at every company.
I think I just personally am
sort of lucky that I have that.
I think that it is
kind of understanding
who your allies are, too, that
luckily, at my own company,
most of the executives are
actually on the Diversity
Council, too.
So even if it's
like a key moment,
you know, that like they have
to make a decision or whatever,
like I think that they now
have trust in certain people.
And they understand
like the broader goals
and like how this is really
good for us as a whole,
as an industry, but also as
society to do these things.
I think a lot of times,
though, it is hard
because I know other people who
don't work in that environment.
It is finding your
allies and kind
of going as like a
group of people, too.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I deliver mental
health services here at Google.
So I'm wondering--
which is very, very
unusual for my career.
So I'm wondering, in the space
of beauty that's women-heavy,
what kind of services
are offered as a benefit
to your staff, to--
you've got major,
major challenges
to deliver, both deliver
services and deliver confidence
and beauty, as people are.
So what are you
doing about that?
MICHELLE LEE: Well, I want
mental health services.
I don't know.
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
MICHELLE LEE: Our services are
not necessarily mental health.
But for our staff, we have a
lot of beauty services, frankly.
We've got like a brow
person who comes in.
It's more sort of--
AUDIENCE: Well,
that's more external
and that, you know, that, I
mean, not that it's not good,
but that there's also a need for
women to be internally happy.
And folks who come from
different backgrounds, folks
of color often have some
internal unbeautiful feelings.
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: And so I just wonder,
I've got to-- that's what I do.
So I always wonder about
the internal beauty.
And when we look at things
in women, like, you know,
I can see the beauty that
comes from external, both bath
gel, brows, makeup.
But when they sit before
me, they're cutting,
they're not eating,
they're drinking too much.
And they can be very successful
in any place in their life.
But they're really damaging
themselves or damaging families
by lack of emotional
intelligence.
And then they don't make great--
they're not a great
team member when
they're before you
because they're
doing all this other stuff.
They've got great
brows, and that's good.
But there's some-- so
I'm just wondering.
Is there--
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So at our larger
company, actually, this
is a somewhat newer
thing this past year.
So we've actually launched
a bunch of groups.
One has been a Latinx group.
One is a women's network,
which just launched probably
about six months ago.
And I'm actually the executive
sponsor of the women's network.
So within a lot of these smaller
groups within Condé Nast,
these are actually some of
those things that are happening.
We'll do other events.
There's smaller
mentorship programs,
not necessarily always
talking about mental health.
But I do think that feeling like
there's a community of people
within your own company
is really helpful, too,
and being able to know people
within other departments that
you can talk to who
are not necessarily
your direct manager, or they're
not a colleague of yours,
I think, has been
really helpful.
But, yes, I would love to have
mental health services, too.
AUDIENCE:
Employee-assistance program.
It's a great idea.
And so is all that other
stuff you're doing.
Thanks for the diversity space.
I opened your magazine
in the nail salon,
and I saw someone
that looked like me.
So for folks that are
older and younger, but they
see hues that are like
them, they get some trust
because they know that you
understand, that you get us,
and you value us as
beautiful persons.
MICHELLE LEE: Well, thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
We have one more time--
time for only one more question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you both for being here.
A lot of people in
their 20s and 30s
spend time trying to build
an identity as they enter
into the workforce, especially
in industries where they're not
fully represented all the time.
And they reconcile how to
fit in while also trying
to be true to who they are.
And so I'm curious to hear
from your perspective,
how did you build your identity
and grow into that confidence
of being who you are?
MICHELLE LEE: Yeah, like I
said, it was not always there.
I think that my personality
is actually pretty reserved.
I was definitely
someone in, like when
I was a junior editor, who I got
very nervous at pitching ideas
in meetings and stuff.
At a certain point, though,
like even something like this,
like people always talk
about like, you know,
public speaking.
I had the hardest
time public speaking.
Like in college, I actually,
I had a terrible phobia of it.
And it's just something that you
end up having to work through.
I think for me, though,
coming up with my own identity
within the workspace,
it was just
finding that
confidence in myself
that, like, if I had ideas, and
they were sort of a bit weird
and outside the
box, that it was OK.
I actually also weirdly think
that social media has helped me
with that, because having
a persona on social media,
like it actually helps me.
In my daily job, once
you become a manager,
you're not always
a creator anymore.
And I think that
I missed something
about the act of
creating all the time.
So now, it's not even part of
my job, but now I'll do videos,
or I'll do other content that's
just for my own Instagram.
And I feel like it's
helping to serve
not only like that
creative hunger
that I'm having, but I also
do feel like it's helping
to define my identity
within the workspace,
but also within the beauty
industry as a whole.
Like when I was talking
before about like how we're
different from
influencers, someone
asked me in another
panel, would you
call yourself an influencer?
And I was like, oh, no,
I'm not an influencer.
But they were like,
you actually are.
I think it's just that
the word influencer has
gotten a strange connotation.
But I do actually think
I'm an influencer in that
certain things I do, or products
that I talk about, or getting
my brows microbladed,
I instantly
have people messaging
me saying, oh,
because you wrote
about that, I'm
actually going to try that now.
So I think that it's
helped me, weirdly,
as I've been working out
what to post on social media,
and what I want the
world to know about me,
it's actually helped me
define who I am, too.
SPEAKER: That's actually
how I found Michelle.
I was admiring her
from afar on Instagram.
And I slid into her DMs and
was like, hey, Michelle,
would you like to
come talk at Google?
MICHELLE LEE: I was like, yes.
SPEAKER: You're an influencer.
You're an influencer, for sure.
Well, there's copies
of the magazine
in the very back
for all those who
may want to grab one
on their way out.
Thank you so much, Michelle--
MICHELLE LEE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: --for being here today.
[APPLAUSE]